it gives me such a feel for the
technological superiority that I've
never had before in an aircraft this is
the f-35 only a handful of pilots are
certified to fly it and three main
things make it the most intelligent
fighter jet ever built
it's sleek design and radar absorbing
body make the plane virtually
undetectable on radar if I have enemy
aircraft coming at me I can see them
before they see me so I get first look
first shot first kill capability the
f-35 collects data from multiple onboard
sensors processes the information and
sends it not only to the pilot but to
ground crews as well
all these computers throughout the
airplane are all interconnected with
fiber so we have a supersonic fiber
network flying around and every pilot
gets a customized helmet that can
literally see through the floor of the
plane we have six windows around the
airplane that I can project that image
into my helmet and see what the
airplanes seeing the plane may be
technologically ahead but the f-35 is
seven years behind schedule
and the cost is skyrocketed is 70%
higher than the original estimate a term
has been used the most expensive weapon
system ever and that's because we're
actually building three variants of the
same basic aircraft for the US Navy US
Marine Corps US Air Force Lockheed
builds the f-35 in Fort Worth Texas the
company could generate as much as six
billion from f-35 sales this year alone
only a hundred and eight have been
completed so far but Lockheed is
contracted to make more than 2,400 jets
by 2039
the combination of the stealth and the
ability of this airplane to use that
stealth how that really translates to
the fighter pilots of the future
it makes them survivable and it makes
them leave